hey guys this is the reuben report i am
the now ebola free dave rubin and i've
got felicia michaels and molly swenson
with me and we've got a ton of stories
so let's get right to it you probably
saw this already there is a crazy viral
video of a girl hitting a guy and then a
guy hitting a girl on the new york city
subway the f train i've been on that f
train and let's take a look you gotta go
have a boy jacket that came out in 1990s
all right
oh
so the guy and two others were charged
with misdemeanor assault after that and
the girl was charged with felony assault
for using a weapon her shoe
in the attack so all right
guy should not hit girl do i have to add
more to that um well i just showed my
son that video yesterday saying look you
know sometimes
some women will go crazy on you and no
matter what happens you can't hit a
woman so yeah absolutely you can't hit a
woman no matter what even if the woman
seems to deserve it because you're the
one that's going to get punished and i'm
glad to see that she got felony assault
because she used her high heel on him
yeah the high heel will hurt oh he also
was a lot bigger than her right so if
maybe if he had been a little guy and
that he hit her that maybe i would feel
slightly different but the size of him
alone you can't do that yeah i mean i
think i think there are actually
exceptions in the case where you can hit
a woman i mean i think if you are an
under imminent threat bodily threat um
to a greater degree of just someone
slapping you on the train if like
i think you get yourself out of the
situation as quickly as possible if that
means stepping aside or if that means
sort of backing off or if that means
shoving the person off of you physically
then you do it but in this case it
didn't seem entirely warranted for him
to slap her really she was slapping
a man should not hit a woman but she was
slapping the camera out of the guy's
hands she was boyfriend
completely belligerent it was also 4 a.m
on saturday morning guaranteed not a
single person on that train was sober
and i think that you know you you get
riled up by the situation and you could
tell there were people fleeing and there
were people running there was like very
fight or flight happening in that video
from everyone on the train and i
i just think that it made a lot of sense
for all of them to get charged and for
her to be charged with the felony
assault for the high heel this thing is
just one of these things where we have
to accept women get a longer leash
because yes we we cut that video we
missed about 20 seconds up top it's
unclear to me whether he knew her or
what started this whole thing exactly
but clearly we're all granting her a
longer leash because she obviously was
the instigator here she hit first and
yet we're all sort of in agreement that
he's sort of more wrong it just doesn't
even sound that right to me when i'm
saying it i think women have to have a
longer leash just so uh
i just really think women have to have a
longer leash so that uh that men can
understand no matter what happens you
can't hit a woman that's there's no
other way around it you know what i mean
so what would you say then to all the
men because i know the comment section
is going to light up and they're going
to say ah these pc blah blah blah she
hit him first he has every right to do
it you can't hit anybody so what would
you say to those people because i know
there i would say if a woman is on the
subway and she's humiliating you she's
probably wearing jessica simpson pumps
and won't have a problem taking it off
to beat your ass but if you're in a nice
place a woman's probably wearing
alexander mcqueen i've got pumps and
she's probably not going to do that you
know so it depends on the pump
i think it depends on the height
women love shoes and if someone's
wearing a fancy shoe she's not going to
beat on you with it yeah i think like
yeah fine hit the woman but now you have
a misdemeanor assault charge on your
record if you just sort of sat down and
didn't do anything or removed yourself
from it you wouldn't have that either i
think so is that what he should have
done so again we don't know the full
context of this but should she have hit
him and then he should have just sort of
sat there in it and just jumped off the
subway at the next stop with that
assault charge then then do it but i
think that most people looking back in
that situation situation would have been
like uh i really didn't want an assault
charge on my record so maybe i would
have done this differently it's all sort
of like a 20 20 hindsight thing so what
do we say to girls right i'm guessing
she's about college age i mean what do
we say to them about yes there are
repercussions like i think
that's right in junior high i think they
should make girls watch that video and
say look a man is not allowed to hit you
but you bear a responsibility on your
actions as well yeah and what is that
man supposed to do he's in a subway he
can't flee the scene go to another car
she's gonna that kind of chick is gonna
follow him and still uh uh because she
feels its power to humiliate a big guy
like that that's a powerful it's like a
drug yeah well she clearly was on a
power trip there i mean just the way she
was speaking to him even the face she
made right before she slapped him like
you could see she was like now i'm
having my moment so they abuse a big
dude about his jacket when he's backed
into a corner sort of literally maybe
final thought on this um the other part
of the video that i think is really
interesting is all the taunting the
laughing the cameraman that's basically
doing play-by-play the guy that jumps
out right in front of the camera to
smile and laugh like what is it about
humans that we really do love this
like even when i saw that video for the
first time you get like a weird rush
from it like are we just like so we're
just repressing all our violent
craziness all the time that you see
something like that and you're able to
get it out i think you're absolutely
right about we repress so much of what
we want to do and when we see other
people behave like that it makes us
giddy like oh yeah we can see how that
goes down without having to participate
in it i do think people think that way
yeah there's a weird duality for me
because on the one hand i get so awkward
when there's confrontation and i just
like get comp i seize up and i don't
know what to do and i get really mad
that it's even happening around me
because of how bad i feel but on the
other hand i like i've always really
kind of wanted to know what it's like to
just punch someone as hard as i possibly
can because i have dreams all the time
where i'm like swinging and can't
actually land a punch i don't know if
i'd actually be able to land a punch and
it's something i'd kind of like to
figure out hopefully i don't but like
there's that well this is just the first
segment we're doing here so maybe you
guys i can get the cups later yeah cause
girl on girl violence everyone's okay
with that we know that much anyway the
moral of the story is don't ride the f
train at uh 4 am in new york city all
right i don't know if you know this but
we are at war right now first off
there's the afghanistan war that
everyone has forgot we just signed some
agreement that we're going to be in
there for another like 12 years or
something but forget about that one uh
then the iraq war kind of ended right
but now we're back in there and we're
doing strikes on isis and then we also
jumped in on syria and now we're
attacking isis in syria of course
they're fighting assad we were gonna
bomb assad a year ago remember that then
we didn't do that we kind of got the
chemical weapons out anyway it's a big
cluster basically and uh we haven't
gotten war authorization on this
especially for the syria part there's
some legal mumbo-jumbo that people are
arguing or at least the administration
is arguing that we have authorization in
iraq because we were there for a
previous war but we do not have
congressional authorization for this war
and rand paul senator rand paul from
kentucky wrote a piece in the daily
beast about this let's take a look
he wrote i believe the president must
come to congress to begin a war i also
believe the war powers act is
misunderstood president obama acted
without true constitutional authority
even before the 90 days expired since we
were not under attack at the time
and he went on to say but in either case
the war is now illegal it must be
declared and made valid or it must be
ended congress has a duty to act one way
or another taking military action
against isis is justified the president
acting without congress is not so what
rand paul is referring to there is the
authorization for use of military force
which was passed by the george w bush
administration and that's the
authorization that obama's using to get
into this war now before the election
last week
for weeks
john boehner kept saying well the
president doesn't call us back to
washington to vote on the war uh so
there's really nothing we can do now i'm
pretty sure he doesn't like when the
president asks him to do anything so
it's a little disingenuous so i'm not
cutting congress slack and i'm not come
to cutting obama slack because i think
we should if we're going to have a war
which is a whole other topic we should
have authorization for the war what do
you think well is it technically a war
or is it a military action what is it
technically being referred to so this is
the league that's the legal mumbo jumbo
that they do and we went into libya when
obama first got in and they called it a
kinetic military action or something so
there's ways to use words but i'm pretty
sure when bombs are dropping on cities
and people and we're attacking
terrorists or whatever it's a war if
canada bombed us we'd call it war right
right i think right i
oh no i was just gonna say i mean i
think
first of all i'm sort of tempted to
discount almost any op-ed written by any
presidential hopeful or read between the
lines at the very least like it's not
surprising that francis libertarian
it's all about you know name recognition
and sort of relevance at this point
which he's trying to maintain with this
and it's not a surprise that he is
libertarian candidate isn't really a fan
of unbridled executive power so like no
surprises there i i think that one of
the more interesting questions raised
and he only does so indirectly is this
question of can
legislation or the legislative process
ever catch up with technology and
technological advances because like you
said what does war mean i mean he
invokes the constitution he and votes
invokes this um this war bill from the
1970s like war has changed so
dramatically i mean constitutionally
obviously right that was like muskets
across the battlefield but even since
the 70s there weren't drones there
weren't any of these things so like yes
a how do we find define war versus
military action and b like
uh you know
how does that change whether or not the
presidential can you the president can
use these
these sorts of acts in order to defend
the country the way he sees fit yeah so
all right so to get to that point
exactly and what you're asking so the
president has 60 days if it's considered
urgent the president has 60 days to get
authorization and then aft if there's no
approval from congress he then has 30
days to end the mission so what rand
paul's arguing is we're past that point
um so every time we've talked about this
and i've brought it up every time we
talk about isis i think part of the
problem is people just don't care how
the government works anymore you know
what i mean like we created a system
where we were supposed to have a
legislative branch to write the laws and
then an executive branch to sign them
into law and a judicial branch to make
sure that they're legal and i just don't
think anyone including the people in
those branch i just don't think anyone
cares is that is that fair to say i
don't think it's about that anyone
doesn't care i think it's like what can
we do yeah you can go out and vote which
most liberals did not this past election
cycle i don't so i don't think it is
about we don't care it's just what what
can we do to change it there's nothing
you can do or i can do to change what's
going to go down at this point and
another thing i would like to add is
rand paul is saying that this war is
illegal and isn't he a plagiarist isn't
it plagiarism
yeah nobody's perfect but i'm i'm kind
of with him on this like i just think if
we're gonna do this we could have a
debate whether we should be doing it or
whether the other countries there should
be fighting isis and we could sit back
and they hate us whether we do it or not
but i think he's at least being
intellectually honest here
versus if this was a republican
president doing this i'm pretty sure all
the democrats would be going nuts right
if a republican president was having a
war without
authorization wouldn't democrats be
going nuts yes i mean there's hypocrisy
all over the place and there's also like
you're both right you know it's part of
it is that
we can't keep up with
what the laws are and why you know the
60 versus 90 days like why was that even
put in place like taking a step back and
thinking about
why these laws are even enacted in the
first place is sort of more interesting
than the nitty gritty details of it and
figuring out you know
if that law is even relevant right now
because it was in 1973 exactly but is it
relevant right now we don't how are we
supposed to know that the president of
all people should know whether that is
relevant enough to pertain to
this specific international security
issue and that's sort of what i'm saying
like i just don't think he cares i think
they have lawyers they all have so many
lawyers that they're just like obama's
lawyers are like yeah yeah you don't
need to go to congress go ahead we got
some legal mumbo jumbo from bush in the
70s and blah blah we'll do that and
congress is like oh it gets us off the
hook we don't even have to vote on it so
then it's good for us so it just goes to
show how broken the system is i suppose
yeah and that he can't even get the
republicans on board with it like he is
strong
no no on board with calling out obama on
it right you know what i mean like he's
straddling in the middle which i find
pretty i worked in the white house for a
little while and i was sort of inclined
to to trust them i mean it's like the
most passionate intelligent hard-working
group of people i've ever been
surrounded by in my life and like if
they can't figure it out then we're
seriously
anyway i don't know call me a strict
constitutionalist or i want the system
to work the way it's supposed to i don't
know i've long thought that satan's
favorite drink is monster energy and now
i finally have someone backing me let's
take a look
look at your m closely
there's a gap right here in the letter m
it's never connected
so you go into hebrew
the letter vav is also the number six
short top long tail
short top long tail you could have here
in hebrew 666 on the can
but my interest is the word monster
what do you see in the oh
there's a cross okay what has christ got
to do with an energy drink let alone the
name monster
so i thought maybe this is a christian
company then
bfc at the bottom of the can do you know
what that stands for
that's the f word
can't
in fact they write it on the side of the
can so i know that's the f word
okay now do you know what a milf is yes
that's on the box
milfs dig it and you will too
this is not a christian company at all
so why would they have a cross on the
can
here is the message anti-christ
666 in hebrews is there another agenda
here
if god can use people that product
so can save
yeah my mom is she a real cut up or what
oh lordy lordy i do want to address one
factual error that we know she made it's
important to note that the number of the
beast is not three sixes but 666 as in
666 which would not be represented in
hebrew uh by six repeated three times
that's according to my notes right here
which were also written by the devil uh
yeah that's intense hebrew school right
there um
well where should we start with this
lady uh she believes what she's saying i
admire people with convictions you know
the last time i saw a white woman talk
about something short on top and long on
the bottom was when they were making fun
of someone's mullet
that's just so ridiculous yeah i think
the question that i'm wondering over
here is did you guys think that she knew
or thought she was a milf as she said
that word is that why you think she
knows what it means to tell you yeah she
was like a milf look right here
um okay
is there some part of you that kind of
admires people that believe these things
that much because like beyond the crazy
part like there's obviously a crazy
element to this but there's another part
of me that i watch someone that like put
this all together really thought this
thing through and it made sense to her
and she linked it all together and like
she figured it out in her own mind and i
sort of admire that you know i mean
there's something about conviction
i'm curious uh what was the first thing
that drew her to it to even think that
way you know she probably was drinking a
lot of monster energy
no i i
yeah i mean i wouldn't say
conviction so much as ignorance i
sometimes am a little bit i admire a
little bit just because yeah i think
that being sort of hyper analytical to
the extent that you can see all sides of
it and not just the size that you want
to see it makes for an unhappy existence
for the most part but like you
you know you can be so so i guess it is
conviction so
intensely believing of one particular
thing that like everything else there's
so so much confirmation bias you don't
even pay attention to anything else but
that makes someone probably pretty happy
and able to go through life just like
yeah so as we mock this woman what
if she's right and monster is in on this
what if monster right you know what if
the joke is on us and monster is uh
satan's drink and you know the devil's
product well she says something in there
and when i was reading it uh that this
is the devil's product or satan's
product and i was thinking well what's
god's product you know what i mean like
it's such a bizarre thing to say guys i
guess would be i drink that reverse
osmosis water are you guys doing that
it's very pure and fresh and you do you
don't do that we're in l.a here no one's
doing that i don't know i think it's
like tempur-pedic personally
it's very fluffy like a pillow and god
is in heaven clouds pillows lube that
would be god's product um one of the
things that i do think is really lube is
god's product yeah there you go
that that i don't yeah okay lube um
one of the things that i think is kind
of funny about this is that um people
always think like okay that makes sense
to her right this idea that satan did
this monster energy drink but don't you
think
satan has bigger fish to fry like this
reminds me of the other side of the coin
when athletes always immediately thank
god they spent their whole lives
training to be better being the best
they can they work out all day long they
do everything they can to be better and
then the second selling good happens
they thank god even though they should
be it's it's the reward of their own
work that they did so it's sort of the
same thing like why would satan she's
thanking satan but don't you think satan
is up to more devious stuff than energy
drinks he likes to uh get on the ground
level i guess with monster drink that's
so ridiculous yes oh so this is satan's
grassroots stuff like get everybody
hopped up on caffeine and then they
start doing mischievous things yeah yeah
yeah yeah you'd think that she'd make
that argument more easily about like
pretty much any alcohol brand out there
pretty much any sort of illicit
substance out there which we'll talk
about later i know but um
i mean i don't know a i'm a jew b i
drink red bull so i don't
apply a jew drinking red bull this panel
is over
google is taking over moffett air force
base they are leasing it from nasa
that's right for the next 60 years
there's moffitt air force base right
there it looks like it's hanging out of
star wars that looks like a transporter
leaving
hoth or something
as part of the lease google is going to
take over the airfield while the u.s
government is going to retain ownership
of it
and it's a little curious what is google
doing uh with an air force base uh we've
got a nasa statement once renovations
are complete hangar one will again be
home to high-tech innovation as
planetary ventures begins using the
historic facility for research
development assembly and testing in the
areas of space exploration aviation
rover robotics and other emerging
technologies hangers two and three will
be used for similar purposes okay so
that's what nasa is saying about it
i thought the story was interesting
because you know we've got virgin
galactic they actually had a pretty bad
uh mishap about two weeks ago but
private companies getting involved in
the space thing so it's a little unclear
as to what google's going to do here but
between virgin and google doing this you
know apple's building that freaking what
is that thing that octagon that i think
is going to be a spaceship and like is
google building elysium that's pretty
much my question like are they are they
building something there that's going to
go out into space and then the earth is
going to go to and the google
employees and the apple people they're
going to live up there and we're going
to be down here with the suckers yes
probably yes probably pretty much but if
so many companies are getting into the
space race i mean is that uh
what is that a safety issue as far as
you know people
doing whatever the they want
that private company is doing it instead
of government yes yeah that's my concern
yeah what do you think are you okay with
this idea that private companies we
don't know exactly what they're doing
here which is why i'm interested in
fully okay with it i think it's great
especially with like cuts to funding for
nasa you know them not having to do the
operations for this means they get to
actually spend more on r d and space
exploration and stuff like that i'm
pumped about private companies getting
into the space race i mean that's like
the only way we're going to get there
and sort of figure it all out i mean
it's like google's building their own
sort of area 51 except we all know where
it is
i'm hoping so do we need nasa anymore
because it seems to me like in during
the cold war like we were in a space
race right russia wanted to get there we
wanted to get there so it made us do it
and because we don't have that anymore
there's just seems to be no yeah we're
doing so we don't even fly you know we
haven't been to the moon do you know
where the last time we've been to the
moon 30 40. it's something like night
did we go to the movies
but it's something like 1971 it might be
in 1973 it might be off but we haven't
even been back to the moon you know you
may now say well we got to get to mars
so forget the moon nothing there blah
blah blah
so yeah i i'm kind of on board this idea
that private companies can get us there
but so is nasa even what's the point of
nasa at this point if we can sort of
farm this off to google and to uh virgin
and the rest of them well i mean i don't
know if this makes sense but the thought
of when airplanes were first invented
and people had were making airplanes but
then you had the air force come on it
wasn't even the air force but military
come in with you know better planes and
they went to war if we're having private
companies make these spaceships i think
the government has to have
the ultimate version and an even
better version than the private sector
does i do think that nasa does need to
exist i mean i'm curious how much were
they using that space
were they using it at all was it just a
waste of money that makes sense that
they should lease it so i'm sure yeah it
was a wisdom there's no doubt about that
and that's another thing i mean i think
that
like my opinion on a lot of other
industries that private uh public
partnerships are sort of what's going to
get us there the faster and with the
best sort of regulations or
lack thereof in some cases but this is i
mean this is a perfect test case right
it's it's something that's
extraordinarily expensive that i don't
necessarily want my tax dollars going
towards but that that i do want the
government still to have some interest
in and i know they do and uh more and
more i think commercial space flight is
going to become something that the
public is you know i think by the by the
time we're all old and sort of in our
wheelchairs our grandkids are going to
be like oh yeah unless last weekend when
i was in space i didn't you know this
yeah
i'm hoping and the only way we're going
to get there is if companies like google
or apple or whatever else virgin uh
start to put a ton of money into it yeah
do you guys think that google and apple
at this point are basically more
powerful than the government like they
pretty much they have a ton of
money the government seems to be broke
like they're building things that are
gonna get us to spa like it seems to me
that if apple literally like if tim cook
wanted to be president of the united
states i don't think it would be that
much of a problem to make that happen
but i think that's the point like he's
not the president and i don't think his
aspirations ever will be he's he's a
private sector guy through and through
and no one who has spent their life
there and then gets into the public
sector is like this was a great idea
i don't think um but if steve jobs was
around don't you think if he had said
all right i want to be president now it
would have just happened like that like
he could have easily been president in
in two years
i don't think so no no i don't think so
i'd i have no nothing to back that up
but it's just a good feeling okay it's
just too many flyover states that would
be like i don't trust that guy you know
too many republicans and people on the
right that would just be like that can
maybe be bought with massive advertising
budgets yeah instead of google leasing
that from the government could they just
lease kansas
and start some work there that's yeah
all right final thought on this do we
have to get off this mortal coil that
we're on whenever i do these space
exploration things i always say i'm a
big sci-fi guy all these movies like
avatar and elysium all these things
where we end up you know basically
raping the earth and there's gonna we're
just gonna mess it up between global
warming and overfishing and all that
stuff do we are we gonna have to is that
the next step in evolution of humans
that we're gonna have to go
it's sort of like battlestar galactica
we were here and we screwed it up now
we're gonna go go somewhere else like is
that it i hope it's not that we have to
but that we want to and that it's you
know our intense
curiosity that gets us there and not
because we're forced off our planet by
imploding or something crazy yeah
because it is within human nature to
want to explore and want to go see
things that others haven't so yeah i i
hope we
do actually finally get some of us off
of here
some of us yeah that was a much more
pleasant ending than mine we have to get
off here maybe we're just going to
choose to and that's what being human is
all about all right let's move on so we
talk about wealth inequality all the
time and everyone talks about the one
percent that it's about the one percent
but as i've mentioned many times it
really isn't the one percent because the
one percent in america sometimes
depending on what figures you're looking
at it could be around 300 000 that
you're making a year maybe around 500
000 something like that not obscenely
obscenely rich so an interesting new
study came out at berkeley university
that it really is about the 0.1 percent
that's the crazy number uh so we've got
a graph here that's going to explain a
little bit more
so
right now in the late 1920s the bottom
90 percent held just 16
of america's wealth considerably less
than held by the top 0.1 which
controlled about 25 so you can see that
at the beginning of that chart on the
left right there from the beginning of
the depression until well after the
second world war the middle class share
of the total wealth rose steadily so the
numbers started separating that was good
great for the middle class good for the
economy
but then those trends have now reversed
and just like the 1920s the top point
one percent hold 22 percent of america's
wealth almost the same share as the
bottom 90 percent of the population and
that's what you can see all the way to
the right on that that they basically
have exactly the same amount the one the
point one percenters not the one
percenters the 0.1 percenters have the
same amount of wealth as the as the
bottom
uh by the way the top one percent or the
top point one percent i should say
consists of 160 000 families and they
average worth uh is about 73
million um so is the one percent thing
it just sounds good right like is that
sort of sounds more romantic it just
sounds more romantic right like you know
sometimes you just need like a bumper
sticker to get things going and if they
had said well it's the point one percent
that would have confused people so
sometimes you just go it's the one
percent and that's just enough is that
is this partly just messaging um no i
mean the point one percent is
astonishing right that's to anyone who
can do basic math is actually more
more crazy and more romantic almost
that's like so so stark the inequality
oh that's interesting so really by
putting it in there they could have
grown the home the point home even more
yeah i think so
i i mean i've i'd sort of like to take
the opportunity to shout out to my
hometown seattle which just raised the
minimum wage to 15 yeah
and having a conversation fifteen
dollars yeah fifteen thousand percent of
what that would be that's true communism
fifteen percent of the salary of the ceo
yeah um nobody i told you they were
trying to get 15 of our income
i think it's i mean i think that's a
huge step in the right direction for
sort of writing this
wrong that exists right now i mean uh
anyone who sort of thinks that that's
going to be a terrible strategy has a
really short-sighted view of how the
economy works and
putting money in the pockets of the
people who are at sort of the lower end
of that graph is
really the best sustainable way because
you're going to end up and you know
they're gonna end up contributing to the
economy better and those companies that
had to maybe initially lay off some
workers because of the minimum wage hike
are gonna be able to hire them again
because so you're saying you don't
believe in trickle-down economics that
if we could just give rich people more
money they'd give more little jobs to
the little people you just don't buy
that no yeah i i think that that um
yeah no i can't even make a joke about
that no i won't even trickle down
economics but i believe that everyone
should participate and
trickle down economics not just the
point one percent yeah yeah um
i don't begrudge these people's success
i really don't and this is what america
is all about i think everyone should
have the opportunity to get but so what
do we do what's like a really see every
time we talk about this then everyone
just oh it's just easy to hate rich
people you know what i mean it's just so
easy to do it so what is the solution
then like should it be like after
50 million you're taxed at 75 if you get
making 50 million you're doing pretty
well now i know in the comments people
are going to be hating me for that even
but like is is there some way to make a
tax system that actually is fair and of
course then they'll they'll send the
money the cayman islands and all that
but within a conversation that we can
have in four minutes like is there
anything we can do to sort of wrangle
this thing in a sensible way do you
think there should just be a simple tax
so just like a flat tax yeah do you
think that's how it should be i don't
know i'll flat tax for everyone above 50
million
definitionally regressive right i don't
know i mean i think that it's probably
not going to be in the tax system or in
the nonprofit system that we figure it
out it really is going to be in
legislation that is
that is meant to just compensate people
better for the work that they're doing
but is there any chance that legislation
could actually happen because don't
aren't these the guys that buy the
politicians and money in politics like
why would the politicians go against
their donors and that whole game that we
talk about constantly it's also like why
would you participate in the giving
pledge then right i mean like there
there are people who got there and who
recognize that they got there because of
you know
not just sort of ruthless business skill
but also like really hard-working people
that they built their company on and so
um and recognize that the inequality is
created dramatically by the the
legislative system and are sort of the
giving pledges attempt to sort of bypass
that i think as well through donations
to nonprofits or whatever it might be
but um no i think that
i think that personally a minimum wage
hike is a good first stepping stone um
and i think that there's a lot of
a lot of other really interesting
approaches you know education and all of
that so that people can feel better
about paying a minimum a higher minimum
wage but like i have a question is there
anything that you guys would do for a
straight week actual labor at fifteen
dollars an hour
is there any i mean i've done jobs for
less than fifteen dollars an hour right
now in your life like as as would you
you know go and and not just because you
see it as like a vacation from sort of
sitting here but like that you could
actually see yourself doing for a month
or a year like when you put yourself in
those
in their shoes or in the shoes of
someone who is working at what used to
be an eight dollar minimum wage that's
not 15 it's like oh yeah no like that's
not enough to live on and that's not a
great existence right so maybe their
taxes should be lower people don't like
that argument either like it's it's a
big cluster is there anything we
can do to get america back on track
because it seems to me that if if i was
in the 0.1
it's in your own vested interest to have
the rest of the people happy because
then they don't come at you with
pitchforks but it seems to me we're like
just angling this to the pitchfork phase
you know what i mean but it's hard to
crawl over a gated community carrying a
pitchfork
it's a little difficult that is a good
point but they can there's the purge and
it's possible
there you go so if you don't want the
purge you should at least think about
maybe some ways that we can get those
those things to separate a little bit
and let's get the middle class back on
track illegal drugs are insanely
insanely profitable yeah the people over
at information is beautiful created a
graph a chart to take a look at and show
you how much more profitable they are
than legal drugs so let's take a look
okay so this is in value per square
kilometer
cocaine 37 million 700 thousand dollars
per square kilometer that's a lot of
money in cocaine uh rice
which is perfectly legal as far as i
know uh 140 000 per square kilometer
sugar cane 262 000 so cocaine a lot more
expensive let's scroll down a little a
little bit and see some of the other big
ones
marijuana we love marijuana on this show
million 666 thousand dollars per
kilometer per square kilometer again a
lot of money what does that compare with
well potatoes are only about 365 000
tobacco uh only
277 000 i thought that one was kind of
interesting opium poppy again illegal a
lot of money barley is only 36 000 that
is a steal for barley to get a a square
kilometer of barley
um is anything before we jump back is
anything jumping out to you here besides
that it's pretty obvious what's going on
here in war on drugs kind of stuff
yes one truffles are notably absent yeah
my troubles would be bigger than
anything right trolls are absurdly
annoyingly even that truffle oil
shaving yeah but also
i think that the other sort of pattern
in here that you see is cocaine
marijuana and opium all also have
medicinal properties which i think
tomatoes and potatoes don't necessarily
happen
what about lycopene they keep telling me
about lycopene isn't that very good for
you i've never heard of that thing you
don't know about
oh it's big
it's big in the tomato community you
know about you're a mother you must know
about lycopene i know nothing about it
you don't know anything about that
after the show
yeah it's supposed to be good it's in
tomatoes they have it says it on the
heim thing anyway when you look at that
is that just an obvious example of why
the war on drugs was an absolute abject
utter give me another
adjective yeah just pure disaster when i
first saw that chart i thought to myself
they shouldn't be showing this to
farmers like you know what i mean like
they're doing a disservice on the war on
drugs right because now the bowling guy
is going to be like well i should make a
little coke over here yeah yeah it's
also fascinating uh and i'm i'm so
interested to see what happens with the
marijuana legalization process in this
country because you know if you think
about it
in all of us history there are only
three
mind-altering substances that have ever
been legal right it's nicotine caffeine
and alcohol and think about the size of
those markets
and think about the fact that none of
those also have medicinal properties the
way that marijuana does and also the
fact that you know since it's been
illegal for all time essentially the
only people who've made any money in
that market are criminals now and so
like if you were to actually let real
business people into that sort of world
the amount of money that they could make
first of all once the risk is sort of
diminished is crazy and the amount and
there's the size of the market is is
ridiculous as you saw from that it's
illegal in the size of
you know the market or the supply and
demand is like that but
i'm fast i'm so fascinated so isn't the
marijuana thing particularly shouldn't
that be a republican issue i did a video
on this last week it seems to me that
they want small government right so they
want the government out of your bedroom
out of your house out of your living
room so if you want you could smoke a
little weed and watch tv that's small
government so they should want that and
they also because they want low taxes
they want to figure out other ways to
raise revenue well you could then start
taxing the marijuana so it seems to me
the republicans if they wanted to be
cool they could actually be cool and
keep their principles here as opposed to
just this being a democratic issue where
it's like oh we like to get stoned you
know the problem isn't like the fiscal
conservatives who are republican because
of that it's the fact that their largest
constituency is the religious right as
well and i think it's more sort of a a
religious it's a really hot topic so
what's the deal with so they don't want
you to get stoned because they don't
want you to have a
spiritual experience outside of jesus is
that
wow i don't
you know
i i i find it there's something in the
bible about like don't take mind
altering substances but then there's
wine jesus i i mean i don't know again
i'm a jew i don't know yeah
i i find the whole thing
interesting when i look at it because
when you look at it it's like when you
see for the first time the chart of all
the different sizes of stars and ours is
this puny little star and then you're
like whoa all this is going on and i was
so surprised that marijuana was the
biggest one given that i always assumed
heroin and cocaine cost more than
marijuana yeah i i mean i don't know the
demand for that the demand yeah yeah
yeah every you know high school kid sort
of tries marijuana not everyone's
getting into heroin exactly so what
would you say to the people that say
well if you make marijuana legal which
now dc just voted on it right the state
of washington has it colorado has it
recreationally not just medicinally what
would you say to the people that say
well if you start with marijuana
then it's going to be cocaine and crack
and next thing you know your kid's going
to be on heroin right i would say if it
starts with marijuana it's most likely
going to end
with a lot of marijuana
rarely do you kick it on up to the other
ones i mean people do but but isn't that
the funny thing about marijuana like i
used to smoke a lot of pot i know plenty
of people that smoke a lot of pot and
there's something about marijuana i
think george carlin said something about
like this that people that smoke
marijuana eventually usually stop by
their own volition without hitting rock
bottom or becoming criminals or doing
awful things for it like there's
something about marijuana that it sort
of resolves itself as opposed to a lot
of these other drugs that that's usually
not the case right the biggest thing for
me is like what are the addictive
properties right like to me and this is
maybe a radical view like tobacco should
be outlawed far earlier than any of
these other things because of the
capacity to become addicted to it like
it's become
genetic not genetically chemically
modified to be as addictive as possible
whereas it's you know only a small
portion of the population of smokers of
marijuana that can actually become
addicted to it and same with cocaine
and all these other things so like
there's also never been an overdose of
marijuana in history like all of these
things when you think about safety when
you think about
not just immediate safety like you could
overdose but also longev like long-term
safety is it gonna give you lung cancer
or whatever else like
tobacco in terms of the drugs on this
list like it's the only product on the
market that kills 50 percent of people
who use it as directed yeah so final
thoughts so so we need a weed lobby the
way we have a tobacco lobby right like
is that really i mean that's already
starting to happen there are now
lobbyists in dc they're very organized
they just don't get out of the house
right right and by the way when george
carlin probably said that joke marijuana
was probably a lot less potent i mean
now marijuana is so potent i you know i
can't abide by that completely you know
fair enough so qatar or qatar we debated
which one it depends i hear on cable
news all the time they pronounce it
every which way guitar or cutter i say
guitar you say uh
qatar
that country over there so they're
getting the world cup in 2022 that's
what it sounds like at least at the
moment now a lot of people are fighting
against that there's all kinds of
reasons because it's going to be hot as
hell there they're also funding a lot of
terror all over the middle east and the
world some big problems there but then
an interesting piece came out in the
guardian that they basically are using
slave labor from north korea pretty much
indentured servants to build the actual
stadium so we've got some more info for
you
according to the testimonies from
workers laborers said that they receive
almost no salaries in person during the
three years that they typically spend
there so they're sending people from
north korea they spend three years
basically get no pay the expectation is
that they will collect their earnings
when they return to north korea but
workers receive as little as 10 percent
of their salaries when they go home and
some may receive nothing at all the
workers essentially are there to earn
foreign currency for north korea so this
is this is pretty terrible stuff and you
know all these things when we have
olympics in different places in world
cup and all that we hear all this stuff
about all these people literally getting
killed there's been many many people
that have already been killed while
building this thing they have no rights
and protections and anything like that
um does this surprise you in any way
like i feel like people just don't
really care about this stuff because it
always happens right it doesn't surprise
me at all and by the way for a north
korean to look around and go this is
some slave labor
it's got to be pretty freaking bad you
know it's got to be pretty bad but it
doesn't surprise me i i could so i saw
you nodding along this definitely
doesn't surprise you no well yeah
being a dick doesn't surprise i don't
think anyone at this point but
you know this is actually a cutter issue
like and an international community
issue anyone who's a world cup fan like
this is an instance where we actually
probably have some power in the
situation to really shine a spotlight on
the authorities and cutters so hard that
they can't hide from it and that they
actually have to address it right now so
what could what could we actually do
well there's you know they mentioned an
organization in that article i think
it's the anti-slavery um anti-slavery
international they're like 175 year or
year old organization that's working on
shining that spotlight and just through
social media through support of those
organizations that are
pushing for anti-slavery efforts we can
we can potentially ensure that they're
no longer enslaved in qatar we can't
really do anything about the north
korean slavery but right at least their
home is the bigger problem here that
people just love these events so no
matter what happens you know there have
been stories uh even this past summer
about that in brazil people were getting
displaced and they were just removing
all these low uh income houses they were
just literally just making people
homeless to build the stadium and to
build concession stands like there's
something about sports and this national
pride thing that it supersedes any kind
of human right thing right right i think
it's obviously it's a terrible thing and
i think any country that
treats their women as second-class
citizens it's no surprise that they're
going to treat foreigners as
second-class citizens which they do but
i also think it becomes a fine line of
here we are having so much aggression
towards the middle east as some of it
warranted some of it and maybe not but
but we have a situ a situation where we
can involve them into a world
organization in a world past time
and i and so it's a hard thing to say do
we not go there now at all or do we
take the good with the bad and say you
know what we want them to participate
because you can't just keep pushing
those kind of countries to the side they
have to participate and maybe part of
the part participation also comes with
people standing up from the other
countries like the united states and
like england and saying you have to take
some responsibility for what is going on
here yeah so i mention that all the time
every time we talk about gay rights and
that's that part of the world every time
we talk about women's rights in that
part of the world all all basically
human rights minority rights all that
they really have none of that in that
part of the world and yet we still grant
them the ability to host these things
women in saudi arabia still can't drive
now it sounds like maybe they'll be able
to drive to vote like it's just such a
mess so what are we supposed to do well
i sort of agree with felicia i mean i
think that
by potentially hosting the world cup
here it's putting them on the
international stage right and it's
giving
other countries an opportunity to learn
more about this country on the other
side of the world that they may have no
idea about and to travel there in some
cases and i think that it's only through
that sort of interconnectivity that
you can even sort of begin to address
some of these inequality issues and by
um you know by meeting these people by
learning more of their customs or just
learning more in general yeah
i'm sort of pro
doing more of this sort of development
stuff in in those countries i like the
idea i just don't know i mean look at
russia like we gave them the olympics
and then it looks like things got a hell
of a lot worse or at least at least
according to the people in crimea i
suppose well i think what what should
happen is the people that actually going
to go to that event should bring their
wives and their rowdy cousins that are
chicks and just get their drink on and
everything and then show the women there
look what we got
i think you're making a breast joke and
let's finish up with breasts insta
breasts they're coming people what are
they take a look women looking for a
bigger bust can now go up a full cup
size the effect is pretty much
instantaneous just one catch it lasts
just 24 hours katie has a big date
tonight her one year anniversary with
her boyfriend i will have surprise for
him
new york cosmetic surgeon dr norman rowe
says women like katie come in when they
have a special event where they want to
look great but most other patients come
in when they just want to try out what
they'll look like with permanent
implants it didn't take long an
injection of a bag of saline and less
than half an hour voila
i love that i will have a surprise for
him which basically means like if i
sleep with him and we wake up the next
morning my tits are going to be a lot
smaller than they were last night um all
right so there's another surgeon now
working on something that's gonna last
two or three weeks so this would be like
vacation breasts not just the one night
breasts um insta-breast uh do you want
insta-breast guess it's a vacation
you have the insta the
breasts but i would like the long
weekend vagina
i mean that is just so ridiculous you
know that's funny i want my leave of
absent booty you know
i i i think that's so crazy if anyone's
gonna jab a needle into my chest it's to
awaken me from a heroin overdose i mean
the whole idea is just crazy because
it's not just they put a needle here i
can't assume it is they put a needle
here and it fills up the whole breast
that means they got to put needles all
over your boobs you know it just seems
like the most ridiculous idea on the
planet okay so we know that look we're
in los angeles here i walk around all
the time in constant amazement of the
ridiculous plastic surgery that people
have uh women of course but now i'm
seeing a ton of it with men um
temporary maybe it's a little better
like you need like a little boost on a
given evening maybe there's something
i'm trying to give these guys the
benefit of it out here geez every time
you get it done and you go to the
bathroom you go from a c cup to b
i mean yeah i you know i think this is
so interesting and i mean it's
i grew up in seattle hippie parents like
that whole world and completely you know
thought never never would i ever get a
spray tan that's happened never would i
ever get plastic surgery that hasn't
happened but like i guarantee every sort
of small boobed woman out there has at
one point maybe googled like natural
breast enhancement or like
boob augmentation whatever that is
and
most of them end up getting scared away
from it or not really willing to accept
the risks with it so like assuming which
is probably not a
great assumption that this is totally
safe this temporary thing
i think that it's actually a really
interesting sort of like training wheels
for plastic surgery and i think that
most small boob girls if they were to
get it to say oh do i maybe want
permanent breast enhancement would
experience it for a couple weeks and be
like that was fun um and then go back
because honestly like when you don't
have to wear a bra all the time it's
worrying about the effects of gravity as
much like it's a better i think it's a
better life so i think there's going to
be like a grass is greener moment that
happens with a lot of these women
they'll end up not going through with it
yeah all right i did not think of that i
actually think that's kind of
interesting like a little test run and
then you can decide if you want to go
forward or perhaps you decide you don't
um what we just have insane image
problems right because even the idea the
idea of the two three week thing the the
24 hour one it's for a date as that girl
has gone on and but even that you're
selling false goods like isn't that a
problem like of course we all sell false
goods all the time you go on a date
women puts on all kinds of makeup the
guy might shave or you know like we all
do that but isn't is there some risk in
that that we're all selling something
that is not real absolutely and that
it's geared specifically towards women
although they do say that they will they
can inject it into a man's calves to
make their calves look attractive
because women have something else yeah i
know i know there's a word there i know
which is code for penis i think for
young people and uh and a man would
never put that in his penis because
women would be like you taste salty
enough anyway
because it's made from saline they won't
even say what's in the two or three week
product
and it's like look this is going into
women's bodies it's not the secret
recipe for coca-cola you know what i
mean like that's pretty that's pretty
crazy um allow me to quote beyonce here
because my producer did a fine job and
gave me a beyonce quote
is it our souls that need surgery not
our bodies
apparently beyonce said that you know
about this beyonce jay-z you know about
beyonce oh uh rings a bell yeah yeah
yeah but is it is it our souls like are
we rotting on the inside while we do all
this stuff on the outside and now we're
doing it temporarily to fake it you go
on vacation and you feel better on the
beach and then you come home back to
your regular life and your regular boobs
and uh you're screwed jeez if someone
could
surgically improve my soul that would be
amazing wouldn't it that would be
absolutely amazing really deep on the
show here
yeah i mean i think it's you know
looking at if everyone's end goal is
happiness what are the means to that end
and some people make the assumption that
it is money or that it is changing your
physical appearance and i you know i
think there's definitely something to be
said for
uh wondering what it would be like to be
in another person's body for a minute or
for a lifetime or whatever that is and
chances that you have to temporarily
experience that whether it's by
augmenting your physical appearance or
just putting yourself in someone's shoes
going and volunteering going and
experiencing life in a different country
anything that sort of changes your
perspective temporarily on your own
situation and puts into perspective your
problems and
is going to be is going to be great and
that's all you know maybe go volunteer
instead of getting a boob job but like
but that's the use of having an amazing
uh like uh creative imagination you know
what i mean by wanting to experience how
other people live their lives by
basically putting a fix a flat can up to
your breast i don't know yeah
all right well i'm with molly the the
meaning of life is trying to get some
happiness i hope you've gotten a little
happiness while watching this and maybe
if you get the breasts let us know you
can comment right down below of course
don't forget to subscribe and we will do
this again next week